tu es dedans je réalise ce que c'est
lykan Hypersport avant ce film je
ne t'avais jamais vu comme lui
avant c'était une première fois pour moi trois
virgule quatre millions de dollars zéro à 60 en
moins de trois secondes nous avions vraiment besoin de
quelque chose qui était  juste différent certains
d'entre eux que vous ne voyez pas tous les jours
il y a sept de ces choses dans le
monde ce gars le garde enfermé dans un
mur rien de plus triste et enfermer la
bête dans une cage est très spécial alors
nous voici dans la suite penthouse qui  est
dans mon esprit construit pour présenter cette voiture
regarde derrière moi voici les moteurs W
lykan Hypersport c'est un turbo double 200 40
milles à l'heure la vitesse maximale se vend environ
3,4 millions de dollars ce qui le rend
parfait pour cet endroit dans notre film est-
ce que c'est le premier  Supercar basée aux Émirats arabes unis,
mais le lichen est l'une des voitures les plus
exclusives au monde limitée à
seulement sept jamais fabriquées.
voitures dans le monde les
gens conduisent leur Bugatti à Starbucks
alors qu'est-ce que vous trouvez vraiment un sujet la
vie de la voiture est faite de
diamants en or blanc et de saphir bleu vous pouvez
choisir la pierre que vous voulez en fonction
de la couleur de la voiture c'est tellement
cher  ce sont les voitures les plus chères que
nous ayons jamais données la franchise rapide Furious
est le premier film que Thomas a
pris dans la voiture comme là-bas en ce
moment vous avez une armée qui frappe
merci d'avoir pris la voiture